on peut participer à un événement et
pouvoir le regretté aussitôt c'est ce
que prouve le comédien gérard jugnot qui
après avoir reçu un césar d'honneur de
comédie aux côtés de ses amis du
splendid vendredi soir dernier a tout de
même taclé la cérémonie bouleversant
pathétique pour le comédien de 69 ans la
soirée n'était pas à la hauteur des
enjeux
même si la situation est compliquée pour
lui le sourire et la bonne humeur aurait
dû s'inviter à la cérémonie
c'est vrai que ça aurait pu être
militant et politique avec un peu de
légèreté et d'humour
il ne faudrait pas faire croire aux gens
qu'il n'y a que les artistes qui s'ouvre
dans cette période pour gérard jugnot
c'est donc une mission ratée de la part
de marina foïs et des intervenants ce
soir-là a loupé bien dommage d'autant
qu'il pourrait selon lui porter
préjudice à leur industrie
c'est dommage parce que ce n'est pas ce
qui va donner envie aux gens de
retourner au cinéma alors jugnot claque
la porte des césars comprenez vous cette
décision
alors kévin est ce que vous voyez cette
décision franchement oui parce que déjà
alors là maintenant j'en ai ras-le-bol
qu'on dise césar on pense à la chatte
accords ayant d'erika sasaki
[Musique]
précieux question vers des camps
illégaux et 1800 reprends-toi bébé
continue et on s'embrasse amo tic
cérémonie était ma descente était
vulgaire aucun moment mais oui je le
comprends surtout cette cérémonie a
l'impression que maintenant il ya deux
générations d'acteurs seule l'ancienne
génération est ce la nouvelle génération
kiki ceux qui se veulent un peu la
vedette ont bien terminé
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord gérer
avec gérard jugnot
moi ça m'a pas gêné à la nationale est
un peu de légèreté et un peu d'humour
eh ben je suis désolé mais moi quand la
troupe du splendid j'étais tellement
content de les voir sont arrivés et
qu'ils ont commencé à faire des vagues
que personne ne comprenait salman qui
devrait compliquer ou les excès le
costume de télé fait partie son clavier
qui a dit c'est c'est quand même coup le
norman trader d'honneur l'année où il ya
personne qui était très très drôle mais
je suis désolé moi je m'attendais à un
truc absolument géniale de la part de la
troupe du splendid que je n'ai pas eues
j'étais très déçu parce que j'étais
tellement heureuse de les voir là et
donc du coup je trouve ça un petit peu
dommage après coup d'aller tacler cette
cérémonie qui pour le coup santander a
plein la tronche
le cinéma s'en prend plein la tronche
donc peut-être on va peut-être un peu
levé le pied et arrêter de les laisser
jouer je vais faire attention à ce que
je vais y être affectés à prendre avec
des pincettes mais c'est que le cinéma
dans l'univers des du spectacle c'est
quand même ceux qui ont eu la chance de
continuer un peu conduite à faire bosser
pas mal intermittents c'est pas c'est
pas les palaces et c'est très compliqué
mais est moins compliqué que dans
d'autres domaines du la musette
sincèrement avec he is over en étaient
les deux seuls à avoir déjà pendant la
bande annonce on n'avait pas tellement
aimé j'ai envie
ainsi que je m'étais chronique d'un
dîner chacun d'un échec annoncé
et surtout nous on est totalement
d'accord avec ce qui s'est passé et ce
que dit gérard jugnot et je suis je me
rejoins complètement benjamin le seul à
seul respiration ça a été ce moment avec
gérard jugnot et ses comparses et
escaliers christian clavier de six roues
est bizarre ça me manque et et drôle
avec également virginie efira qui a été
super le meilleur espoir féminin qui a
été ce petit moment de fraîcheur et
voilà quelques pastilles mais il faut
quand même le reconnaître quand elles
arrivent marina foïs qui se prend pour
meryl streep incarne alors merci déjà
rachel d'avoir établi à vérité c'est
vrai qu'il ya deux semaines j'avais eu
le pire lorsque je me trompe je fait un
mea culpa donc quand j'ai raison
j'aimerais bien qu'on lise aussi ces
gens-là finition des raisons et non ce
que je voulais dire aussi donc rachel tu
as raison mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que heu moi j'ai perdu et c'est
que je peux comprendre la réaction de
gérard jugnot
c'est vrai que les gens lorsque
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une crise
un peu anxiogène et les gens lorsqu'ils
viennent voir les césar ils viennent
pour s'évader à l'image du cinéma ils
viennent pas là pour voir un meeting
politique c'était un meeting politique
c'était politisé on s'était peut être
utilisé au maximum et on s'est fait
chier le monde